a few days ago Valley Metro the public
Transit Agency in Phoenix played willing
host to something called No Pants Light
Rail day now as the name would seem to
indicate no pants Light Rail day is a
day when people ride the light rail in
Phoenix without any pants um the Phoenix
New Times advertised the event last week
so here's what the article says after a
4-year wait Valley residents have an
excuse to take their pants off in public
again Phoenix's no pants Light Rail ride
returns this weekend for the first time
since 2020 as the name of the event
implies it involves locals hopping
aboard Valley Metro Rail without any
pants skirts or shorts participants are
dressed in underwear tops and shoes
though the infamous event equal uh equal
part flash mob and urban prank is
scheduled for Sunday it's one of
Phoenix's unique and cheeky events
earning its underwear clad participants
stares glares and smiles from onlookers
or fellow Light Rail passengers